welcome back to New Rock stories I'm
Eric Boss and this is a breakdown of
black panther what kind of forever a
film that teaches us how in grief there
is power in a truly remarkable feat of
Cinema to advance the thematically rich
thought experiment of wakanda somehow
without its beloved hero t'challa the
late Chadwick Boseman we must dive deep
into this film to celebrate how director
Ryan coogler pulled this off breaking it
down scene by scene not just for the
marbled Easter eggs really for what I
consider to be even more rewarding and
easier to overlook filmmaking choices
but quickly just want to thank the
sponsor of this video inkbox spoiler
warning if you have not seen the film
yet over black we hear the voice of
shuri praying bust please allow me to
heal my brother now of course boss is a
panther deity of wakanda the entity that
endows the Black Panther with their
powers she prays because she needs to
regrow the heart-shaped herb all of
which was burned by killmonger in the
2018 film and boss is believed to be the
spiritual source of that herb shuri
scrambles in her lab to heal t'challa by
regrowing this herb synthetically with
her AI griot voiced by Trevor Noah it's
a gripping 90-second long take no
cutting documentary style underscoring
this is a true medical emergency now the
Herb's DNA is shown in a double helix
configuration with white orbs while the
2018 film opened with grains of black
this is orbs of white already cast in
the wakandan color of mourning reports
that the DNA's confidence rate is 25
then 29 sure he says good enough and
orders it 3D printed but her mother
ramonda enters to report your brother is
with the ancestors now t'challa's
illness is never specified in this film
out of respect to the late Chadwick
Boseman whose death in August 2020 after
a private battle with colon cancer
prompted a rewrite of the script this
way Ryan coogler and co-writer Joe
Robert Cole avoid exploiting boseman's
death as a plot point or a spectacle
piece it's not really about how t'challa
died it's about how to mourn and so by
using simply the word illness they imply
it wasn't some Cosmic MCU battle but
really a more grounded way that many of
us have lost our loved ones and truly
the way that we lost Chadwick shuri is
our focal character for this story and
this movie evolves or is comic relief
Kid Sister to a true instrument of grief
who through her journey teaches us how
to heal ourselves because while she's
really trying to heal her brother in the
opening minutes her true mission of this
film is to heal herself like the proverb
physician heal thyself shuri's wounds
will only be treated when she takes the
remedy that she's trying to produce for
her brother and once she properly
Grieves her lost family Bost answers her
prayers with t'challa's Legacy t'challa
is buried in a private family plot as
water is poured in soil hydrating this
plot we're sure he will later plant
future heart-shaped herbs shape away the
shaman successor to spiritual Elder Zuri
in the 2018 film and Terrace t'challa as
the son of t'chata in The Descent of
bashenga the first black panther and
while it's all in wakandan the term
black panther is in English suggesting
that like Namor this is a name given to
the hero by The Outsiders of this world
while t'challa himself is buried here
his ceremonial casket is paraded through
the streets of the golden sea of wakanda
a festive celebration of life shuri
Ramona and all the wakandans wear the
color white as they did while they were
mourning to Chaka in the 2018 film we
passed a naval guard playing a water
drum which is a cameo by Jabari Exum a
drumming and movement coach from the
2018 film and a friend of Chadwick
boseman's whom Lupita Nyong'o said would
drum while they did their fight training
for this movie became a very important
part of their Rhythm one way that they
tried to keep Chadwick's Spirit fighting
alongside them in this movie a tribute
billboard with what kind of lettering
translates to the panther king forever
lives in us and rests with the ancestors
overhead wakanda Jets crisscross in a
flyover leaving exhaust trails that are
crossed like the wakandan chest salute
the Royal Cemetery gate is flanked by
statues of bashenga on one side and a
female on the other both of them have
Panther statues at their feet the female
could be bashanka's wife or her sister
either way both t'challa's sister and
his wife play key roles in furthering
his legacy as they salute his casket and
it rises up into the jet the music is
ludwigsen's ancestral plain theme to me
the most powerful Melody from his
oscar-winning score it's the music
t'challa heard when he entered the
ancestral plane to join his ancestors in
the 2018 film and it's the music he and
we here now and then under reverence
silence the Marvel Studios Fanfare
replaces typical imagery of Avengers
with moments and Script quotes from
Chadwick Postman as t'challa first the
script quote in Civil War when he told
Natasha about the green field with
Boston segment after his father died
then our very first shot of Chadwick in
the MCU when he looked over his shoulder
when he's in Vienna in Civil War then
t'challa in a suit with his mask off
then the script quote t'chella asks his
father in The ancestral plane tell me
how to best protect wakanda I want to be
a great king then the script quote
t'challa said before the U.N in times of
Crisis the wise build Bridges while the
foolish build barriers then an image of
black panther with the mask on then the
script quote what happens now determines
what happens to the rest of the world
which I think was just a line for the
Black Panther trailer marketing
throughout 2017-2018 then the script
quote if anyone found out what we truly
are and what we possess they could
destroy the world it's my duty to
protect it which is an alternate line
for the movie that t'challa said to
Nakia when they walk through the streets
in Black Panther and then t'challa
Crossing his arms in salute then we see
the letters of Marvel Studios where the
flickering images are more famous
moments of t'challa t'challa walking
into Sherry's lab in the 2018 film
t'challa celebrating at Warrior Falls
after he defeated in Baku t'challa
hugging his father tachaka in The
ancestral plane in the 2018 film The
Moment t'challa drops out of the royal
Talon fighter to help Nakia in the 2018
film then on the inside of the V
t'challa swinging from the Rhino horn in
the battle of the 2018 film then on the
art the child and shuri stepping out of
the portal in endgame to give cap some
backup and then on the M t'challa
shouting the words wakanda forever an
Infinity War right before the charge and
it ends as it has throughout many phase
four titles clearing all of these images
with t'challa punching the ground to
release the shock wave and behind all
this is a purple Hue the color of the
heart-shaped herb fitting beautiful and
poignant tribute we transitioned one
year later Queen Ramona played by Angela
Bassett in a powerful truly oscar-worthy
performance addresses the UN who tries
to shame her for not sharing wakanda
vibranium with the outside world Richard
Schiff Toby Ziegler from The West Wing
is credited as the U.S Secretary of
State an office switch during the Civil
War era was held by Thaddeus Ross in the
MCU all right Peter Thunderbolt Ross
William Hurt as well as leader of the
merchant tribe Dorothy Steele who plays
a small role in this movie but also died
during production the French Secretary
of State reminds us that vibranium
cannot be detected by known metal
detectors as we saw in the 2018 film
went to Chala Nakia and nikoya entered
that Korean nightclub Ramona defends the
wakandan's actions as safeguards against
the hostility of other nations saying
she knows they whisper bird the king is
dead the Black Panther is gone and now
is the time to strike calling out their
treacherous speed Trails of their
Goodwill the last time wakanda appeared
before the U.N and we actually see these
actions at a wakandan Outreach Center in
onsongo Mali one of the many Outreach
centers to challengeuri opened around
the world including one in Oakland that
we saw at the end of the 2018 film
Fringe Commandos attacked these
scientists but Okoye leads dorm Elijah
to the rescue and we find out that one
of these signs is actually one of the
dormologically undercover aneka played
by Michaela Cole she uses vibranium
daggers against okoya's insistence issue
spear the fact that the dorm Elijah
already had to have someone here
suggested they must have anticipated
this attack and or other Outreach
centers have already been raided and we
learned in a Twist this attack had
already happened hours before the UN
speech so the dorm Elijah escort these
Commandos to the U.N to shame the French
let our gracious response to this
incursion
be an olive branch yeah okoya is French
and other non-english languages in this
movie it's translated and it subtitles
the color white wakandan is always
translated into yellow and the language
of telecon is translated into blue and
of course it's hard to hear the word
incursion in the MCU and not think of
Reed Richards warning us about
incursions heading to Secret Wars and
Multiverse Madness we should note that
in the 2015 John Hickman New Avengers
run that kicks off that Illuminati
freakout over incursions that seems to
be Marvel Studios road map for how we're
leading to that the initial incursion
Point appears where over the Skies over
wakanda then on to an ocean Expedition
where a team of divers is using a
one-of-a-kind vibranium detector to
investigate an underwater drill that got
busted on a deposit of vibranium they're
led by Dr Graham actress Lake Bell who
voices Natasha Romanov on what if the
telecon Warriors Dart passed them in the
shadows and we hear louder and louder
their siren song the diver Salazar and
Jackson get transfixed by a phantom
jellyfish before the teleconians kill
them I gotta imagine this was at least a
nod from Kugler to Jordan peel for the
jellyfish inspired UFO jean jacket and
nope which hypnotically led people to
their Doom but we got a note in this
movie not that kind of Doom the
telekinesians break the the surface of
the water and sing hypnotizing crew
members to walk off the deck into the
water this is based on Sirens of Greek
mythology humanoid creatures who would
lure Sailors to their Shores with their
songs but then cause those Sailors to
crash on the rocks of the islands a Tuma
nomura and other telecommands bore the
ship in attack in the comics atuma is a
rival to Namor but here he's kind of a
second in command they all wear
breathing masks filled with water so
that they can move on land similar to
the moisture masks so still suits in
Dune Dr Graham departs in a helicopter
but it crashes revealed to have been
thrown by its tail by Namor flying with
his ankle wings and we cross dissolve
from this into the border of wakanda
making it look like nemour is flying
into that Kingdom as this will be the
next place he visits CNN's Anderson
Cooper cameos reported on the UN speech
he looked closely at the ticker along
the bottom of the screen it reads Scott
Lang continues to promote his book look
out for the little guy that book is
ant-man's autobiography that he promotes
an Ant-Man that was quantumania which of
course is the next film on Marvel
studioslate ramonda finds shuri in the
lab we're sure he's designing the EXO
suits that will eventually become
okoye's Midnight Angel suits the wakanda
letters on shuri's screen translate to
Flat Line which might just be one of her
design template tool options but also
might just be an unfortunate word
combination reminding her of how a year
earlier she found out her brother
flatlined in the same spot now Ramona
says that the AI griote unnerves her
saying one day artificial intelligence
is going to kill us all and sure he says
AI isn't like the movie's mother it does
exactly what I tell it to which is
pretty odd exchange for a world that has
definitely had to do with Ultron but
Ramona tells Shari she wants to take her
on a trip to and her two lead behind her
carboo bead bracelet and her comboyo
earrings setting up shuri to have two
separate ways of tracking her after she
leaves behind her bracelet on the bridge
Ramona takes shuri to a Riverside
campfire to partake in a morning ritual
of Bernie in the funeral garments nearby
elephants bathed in the river elephants
are known to have complex grieving
rituals as well traveling long distances
to the sites on the anniversaries of the
deaths of family members Guided by an
instinct similar to the hand of
t'challa's spirit that Ramona mentions
here but sure he always a scientist is a
skeptic she says the hand was a
construct of Ramona's mind shuri says if
I sit here and think about my brother
for too long it won't be these clothes I
burn it will be the world and everyone
in it now later when shuri enters the
ancestral plane she wears these funeral
garments as the room around her catches
fire so in this moment she talks about
birding the world she is invoking
killmonger and his rage Ramona nearly
tells Sharia a secret about t'challa
they are interrupted by Namor now the
comics Namor was the Submariner ruler of
Atlantis Marvel's first mutant when he
was introduced in timely Comics 1939 but
here the characters been frequency by
Ryan coogler to be played by tenoche
Huerta from the realm of telokan but
still having the pointy ears and the
ankle Wings namora says this place is
amazing
the air is pristine on the water
my mother told stories about a place
like this a protected land with people
that never had to leave
never have to change who they were
what reason do you have to rebuild your
secret to the world I am not a woman who
enjoys or repeating herself who argue I
had many names
my people call me
but my enemies call me no more is The
Feathered Serpent deity worshiped by the
ancient Mayans telecon is based on
talocon an Aztec afterlife that takes in
those who die from drowning or anything
associated with rain or water the native
language spoken by the teleconil
according to tanoshuerta is based on
ancient Mayan languages sure he observes
that nemour is covered in vibranium
meaning that she could just kind of
eyeball his metallic chess pieces and
pearls and tell that they are all
vibranium despite their different color
and texture from the vibranium she works
with she's such an expert she just knows
vibrating when she sees it the more
leaves ramonda with the American
vibranium detector and a vibranium conch
shell to call him and I just love this
detail because it Embraces what I was
told as a Florida kid that when you put
a shell up to your ear you can hear the
ocean nope you're really hearing them
all the Council of Elders gathers
including Baku of the mountain tribe the
Elders of the River tribe mining tribe
border tribe and Merchant tribe as mbaku
enters this room he eats a veggie a call
back to his line in the 2018 film one
more word and I will feed you to my
children
I'm kidding we are vegetarians the door
milage stand on columns for the
different parts of the Kingdom on the
columns are written Golden City
kingsguard River tribe Mighty tribe
behind each guard are the Tableau
symbols in red clay just like the floor
of this throne room they originally
designed this throne room so we made it
the same clay so that all the different
rulers of the different tribes would all
stand on the same terrain one of these
symbols is a large tree with expansive
branches and equally expansive roots in
the past I've compared this to the Idris
Elba world's tree of Asgardian mythology
but in this case I like the symbolism of
As Above So Below as above we have the
kingdom of wakanda as below we have the
kingdom of talukan now behind each door
melange guard some new text has been
added to the throne room the full
transcription is rest in Power King
t'challa our hero twas an honor wakanda
forever Ramona sits upon the throne and
on the seat of it the wakandan
translates to wisdom and loyalty actor
Isaac devancale plays the River tribe
Elder as he did in the 2018 film and
surmises that no more must have swum he
says 100 kilometers to bypass the River
border makes us Wonder a bit about the
wakanda feed because it is certainly
more than 100 kilometers to the nearest
ocean or sea based on the map of wakanda
from Civil War but it would be within
100 kilometers of Lake Victoria which
would be a nearby lake that no more
could swim to up the Nile for the
Mediterranean Sea I had broken down this
geography in other videos but I think
the map does check out there Ramona
Sherry nikoye deduced that there must
have been a second vibranium meteorite
that landed in the ocean which means for
them the one gift from the heavens that
made wakanda unique a vibranium
meteorite was also a gift that the
cosmos gave to the ocean of Earth but it
also poses a question where in the
cosmos did all these chunks of vibranium
come from I look forward to exploring
that many of the other questions from
this movie in future videos but Everett
Ross returns to the 2018 film and tells
shuri nikoya that the scientist is an
MIT student so they head to MIT remember
this is Tony Stark's alma mater and
currently the college attended by MJ Ned
and Flash shuri intercois fion Riri
Williams played by Dominique Thorne
future ironheart Thor actually initially
auditioned for the role of shuri for the
2018 film and you can tell there's an
inherent Sisterhood between the two
women as intellectual equals kind of
like what we initially saw between Tony
Stark and Peter Parker in Civil War
entries dorm room door is a note collats
conjecture 300 plus one this refers to
the 3x plus 1 problem with the Colette's
conjecture that's the most famous
unsolved problem in mathematics
presumably this is what Riri is actively
working on in her Spare Time inside
bravery's room is the flag of the city
of Chicago that is her hometown and
Okoye gets impatient get out of my dorm
get out
hey
I'm warning
toward me see how they teach the
children to treat their guests
small small girl
I am going to give you two options
you can come to wakanda
conscious or unconscious yeah remember
in the 2018 film okoya used an itchy wig
to go undercover in the outside world in
Korea now she just covers her head
tattoos with makeup but it presents its
own complication they go to riri's
Warehouse where she said she had to
build a quantum computer to crack her
own encryption Quantum you say I mean
the future of technology in the MCU is
certainly Quantum Riri actually could
have been the friend who helped Cassie
Lang build that Quantum Tech that leads
to all them getting sucked into the
quantum realm and Quantum media Quantum
Quantum Quantum Quantum sure he notices
Riri blueprint asking if it's quote
Stark Tech so it's not just that shuri
is building her own exosuit inspired by
Iron Man she is actually using start
text schematics means she might be
building this with Tony's blessing
through one of those MIT grants like the
one that he announced in Civil War
Tony's speech at MIT would have been
like eight years before this but I
assume the grant program is still
functioning Riri says there's an entire
YouTube channel dedicated to sightings
of me which is another Peter Parker
parallel with Civil War and homecoming
showing YouTube videos of Peter's
heroics throughout Queens this might
also be an account you can imagine Carla
Khan having something to do with either
posting content there or definitely
replying to it Okoye takes off in a
muscle car shooting on a motorcycle and
re-ray Suits up in her Mark 1 armor when
it Powers up notice it makes the same
sound effect as Tony starts for pulsers
[Music]
honestly this is my favorite suit of all
the suits that Riri wears in this film
the other one looks a little gun to me
to me but here there's no full coverage
of the body it's really just like bars
and straps and rigging and zip ties and
she has this chest reactor in the shape
of a heart the whole Escape is just very
reminiscent of Tony Stark's initial
escape from the cave in his unfinished
Mark 1 suit and the first Iron Man film
Riri makes its rapid climb into the
night sky but she runs out of oxygen and
balls reminding us a lot of Tony's first
real flight over Los Angeles when he
froze over and fell and just caught
himself at the last second rigor catches
herself here and Glides along the river
Sharia nokoye flee the FBI sure he uses
her spear to Anchor her turn a
government drone closes in on them but
Riri shoots it down and joins the other
two in a Victorious Glide over the
wreckage until boom you looking for this
a water grenade completely wrecks them
in atuma and nomura and friends join
them on the bridge jump in front of the
back of a freaking whale the actors
actually said this duel between Okoye
and the Tuma took the longest of any
fight sequence of the film to shoot as
they kept having to go back and reshoot
parts of it I love how atuma's strike
slides Okoye back on her feet she has a
vibrating him Spear and she is not used
to ever having to repel other vibranium
with it so defeated shuri requested the
telekneal take her and Riri to meet
Namor directly the next morning Everett
Ross arrives at this crime scene where
he meets Valentina Allegra defontaine
Julia Louis Dreyfus the shadowy
government figure from the Falcon Winter
Soldier and black widow who is now
established as of this film as the
current CIA director in the MCU and
Ross's ex-wife this is a huge deal for
the political hierarchy of the MCU this
is what I was referring to in my tweet
when I said that the hierarchy power of
the embassy was changing and they said
oh you're gonna get mad at me when you
find out what it was but yeah I think
it's extremely significant now we don't
know how long Val has been the CIA
director because John Walker didn't
really seem to know she was and the CIA
director is a president-nominated and
Senate approved very public figure well
the average person might not know who
the CIA director is someone like John
Walker would know but either way this
means that Val's recruitment of Walker
and recruitment of Elena belova to kill
Hawkeye all of these things said the
full weight of the US government behind
it and now since Val is going to be
leading the Thunderbolts the Thunder
volts is going to be a much more public
Squad of killers I think this is
definitely going to tie into secret
Invasion and Captain America New World
Order and yeah Thunderbolts and Val just
shot at the top of my list as scroll
suspicious and Everett Ross right behind
her okoya reports losing shuri and Riri
the doorways behind her are now flanked
with text on sacred ground may we find
and on the other side the wisdom of the
ancestors now it actually seems to be a
misprint in the shot of akoye but it is
what it reads later when sure he enters
the ancestral plane version of this room
when it transforms into literal sacred
ground where shuri finds the wisdom I'll
be a complex wisdom of her ancestors
ramonda is reminded that Okoye raised
her spear against her own husband
referring to wakabi Daniel kaluya's
character from the 2018 film who does
not appear in this movie but Ramona says
that will copy is somewhere that Okoye
can visit him anytime she wishes so this
establishes that wakabi is alive and
well somewhere Ramona shouts
of the most powerful nation in the world
family it's gone have I not given
everything God damn what a great actress
like Wanda for the mothers of the MCU
with great power comes great loss Ramona
also snaps to the koi for standing at
killmonger's side when she and sure he
had to flee to the mountains something I
was surprised to hear she still had a
grudge over but it's all coming out and
it hurts Okoye resigns for spear Ramona
finds Nakia in an orphanage in Haiti and
we catch a quick glimpse of a boy who
later gets revealed credit scene to say
two Saints played by young actor
actor and the post credit scene has been
field as t'challa inakiasan t'challa son
of t'challa That's The Familiar greeting
between the boy and his grandmother
shuri and Riri wake up in a glowworm
Cavern which we later learned is 140
meters below kind of a middle ground man
cave for no more to be alone and to
paint because yeah you can't paint
underwater sure he has told to put on a
traditional telecon dress rear says it's
some super villain [ __ ] like Princess
Leia referring to the slave Leia bikini
and Return of the Jedi Belle from Beauty
and the Beast and she says that white
chick from Indiana Jones referring to
when Marion had to put on the white
dress and Raiders of Lost Ark but Bell
for Beauty and the Beast there wasn't
anything that messed up about that I
mean I guess it's kind of weird that a
bunch of like clocks and candles and
dishware is like yeah put on that sexy
dress for that Beast this whole movie's
kind of Stockholm syndrome what kind of
forever tattoos for now ink box tattoos
last one to two weeks so you can express
yourself with a tattoo for the mood that
you are in right now without worrying
about whether or not you'll want it well
forever there are over 10 000 tattoo
designs to choose from you can even
create your own totally unique tattoo
easily using inkbox's custom platform
and if you're a pro artist or an ad a
doodler you can draw your own tattoo
with one of inkbox's freehand tattoo
markers so they come in these little
packets here and the one that I want to
try is this adorable boo-boo ghost
tattoo ghost are rad I just really like
the design I'm gonna put it like right
here on my wrist I think that's a good
spot for it so to give you this primer
wipe you wipe the area
why and it's nice and dry and primed as
they say feeling it and
laziness okay it's now my hand and I'm
just gonna let this sit we're gonna let
some time pass and then check back in
later after it's fully developed because
it takes about 24 hours for a dark blue
or black color depending on what your
skin is
okay some time has passed and uh check
it out I have ghostly ghostly pale skin
so it's you know it's like a dark blue
see unlike other temporary tattoos ink
boxes ink sinks into the top layer of
your skin and then after a week or two
it fades as your skin naturally
regenerates the ink is plant-based
cruelty free and water resistant and
here we are I've been ghosted in the
good way ink boxes tattoos are perfect
for switching up your style testing out
your next tattoo idea and make for
Unique gifts for the upcoming holiday
right now you can use the code new
rockstars to get 25 off your entire ink
box order and there's no minimum order
requirement but you can only use it once
so stock up the code will only be good
until the end of 2022 to get started
with inkbox just click the link in the
description to start brow Nakia searches
a village in the Yucatan in Mexico
speaking Spanish which shows up as white
subtitles but the moment she switches to
ancient Mayan the language of telecon
the subtitle switched to the color blue
now more brings shuri into his painting
room where he explains his backstory
with his mother in 1571 in Zama which
was the original name of Tulum which is
one of the best preserved Mayan cities
on the coastal Yucatan Spanish
conquistadores gave them smallpox now
1571 this would be about 50 years after
the eternals witnessed the Spanish
conquering of the Aztec capital and then
parted ways you could argue had they
finished the job we might not have
gotten them or nomura says they prayed
to shock their God of rain and abundance
for a cure now chalk is the Mayan Reign
deity but NASDAQ mythology that God is
named slalok who rules over slalo Khan
Namor says shock LED them to a plant
underwater sprouting from a vibranium
Rock their heart-shaped herb but an herb
that grows underwater namora's mother
and just his plant along with the rest
of the tribe and they wake up with blue
skin gas paper air having to dive into
the water so they can breathe where
their skin turns back in normal color so
other than the more the slavicaniel
turned blue only when they are out of
water we see the birth of nemour as he's
born in underwater he is the first son
of salukan with wings on his feet and
ears that he says were pointed to the
sky and he calls himself a mutant he
says that he has the ability to age
slowly and breathe both through air and
through water in the MCU still Gathering
what the rules of mutant kind are but it
seems like every mute must have some
kind of genetic precondition that leads
to their physical States turning out
different from everyone else but it also
presents the question do all mutants age
slowly because according to the latter
Fox X-Men films that definitely seem to
be the case to fulfill this mother's
dying wish young the more returns to the
land where he finds a slave plantation
and a priest says Thou Art a demon Son
Of Satan and not yet Padre but amethyst
is coming soon the teleconil burned the
plantation and the more reveals the
origin of his given name that they
called him El Nino SI nemour the boy
without love which she embraced as Namor
because he has no love for the surface
world so namura wasn't just to nochuerte
pronouncing it differently they actually
worked in a bit of Spanish wordplay to
cast no more as proudly without love for
humans no more gives Shari a deep sea
diving suit to show her talukan and at
first I wondered wait where did the
teleconil get these until he realized oh
right yes Salazar and Jackson sure he's
wearing a suit that a diver was just
murdered in nice have fun hope it
doesn't smell bad so namora takes shuri
down through this tunnel in the water
which seems to be a kind of current but
I don't know maybe it's a type of
Waypoint to a hidden Earthly realm kind
of like that watery portal that leads to
talo and shung Chi now I know China and
Mexico are different countries with
completely different cultures and
histories but I'm just saying talo
talocon both of them hidden mythological
Realms on Earth there might be a
connection there the amazing music of
Buddha kush and Ludwig's cone La Brisa
guides us into telecon which is revealed
from Mayan script translating to English
the way other location titles translate
from wakanda to English the talukoneo
played the Mesoamerican ball game the
modern version known as ulama this was
played by Mayan peoples where a rubber
ball is bounced from your hip through a
hoop on the wall you might know it as I
did from The Road to El Dorado the
telekinil great no more with a salute
forming their hands kind of in the shape
of a throne but also an open shark mouth
as the telecon throne is a giant shark
Jawbone
I regret that joke immediately Namor
shows sure his Central Palace that is
made fully a vibranium and is lit by a
powerful light his own Golden City that
he must protect Nakia Waits on a Yucatan
Beach for griot to track shury's
earrings and then dives into a water
hole in the jungle a land-based waypoint
to talocon now notice how nakia's suit
is green the color of her River tribe
but costume designer Ruth e Carter
Incorporated blue to look like a river
snaking Through the Jungle effectively
telling the story of nakia's rescue plot
in the second act the more it gives
shuri a bracelet of friendship the same
bracelet worn by his mother both an
olive branch but we later learned the
plant DNA that shuri can use to
re-synthesize the heart-shaped herb so
just to track the jewelry swapping going
on in this movie shuri leaves her camoyo
bead bracelet for Ross to find
technically Val bug that bracelet but
she keeps her earrings which is how they
track her down meanwhile nemour notices
that shury's wrist is bare as she
surrenders herself to him which she
knows that he won't see is suspicious
because she was not wearing that
bracelet earlier at the Riverside fire
ritual for her mother's request so
nomore gives her a bracelet which
becomes the Cure that she's been seeking
throughout this whole film I love it
when costumes and accessories have a
practical in symbolic function in the
film shuri tells no more that t'challa
suffered in silence and when he finally
asked for help she couldn't now this is
a nod to Chadwick Boseman in real life
who was diagnosed with colon cancer in
2016 and he told pretty much no one he
suffered in silence while shooting Black
Panther and infinity war and endgame
Ryan coogler recently told Anna he see
coats in a podcast that he noticed
Bozeman would struggle during the
warrior false scenes in the 2018 film
and at the time coogler didn't really
know why some days when I would find him
doing things that were kind of
inexplicable like we would do these
these things in the water you know the
waterfall stuff so it would take him
like a long time to warm back up like
you have to be in like in a warm intent
for like a long time and I'd be like I'd
be like man I'd be like that's odd you
know you know I'm saying things like
that or you know some some days I would
find him just like incredibly sad but
looking back I'm like oh man my man's
was dying it's a shocking thing to
realize and it's also a thing where it's
like oh yeah I can't quit If he if he
did all that while he was going through
that you know this is just grief so it's
like we gotta push through the more
tells Siri my ancestors would often say
only the most broken people can be great
leaders he's trying to appeal to her
grief as a kind of compliment of wisdom
but the more reveals the whole point of
all this is that he plans to to attack
the surface world preemptively and he
wants straight to get wakanda to join
them in that war and while he seems
crazy they see me cut to confirms that
to be essentially the case the Secretary
of State tells Val and Ross that the
president plans to invade wakanda no
more meets Ramon on the beach and warns
her that he will kill her if any further
intrusions happen to talukan Meanwhile
Nakia arrives in history and riri's
Telecom he'll guard with a fatal blast
shuri reunites with her mother no more
returns to find that dying guard and
nomura goats him to strike back so no
more descends to his shark bone Throne
where it looks like the teeth are
actually made of vibranium he wears a
feathered serpent headpiece of cuckoo
Khan I like the symbolic contrast in the
directional coronation of the two
kingdoms wakanda's ruler Rises up from
the ancestral plane to sit the throne
telecon's ruler descends down from the
Sun to sit that room telecon angrily
rallies his people to war
done
Ikea reunites with the koye in wakanda
aquaya says that Nakia left right after
thanos's attack when you left without
saying a word
it hurt
how you regret not being there with all
of you it was not easy
he was King and black panther to
everyone
I told me
he was everything this means that Nakia
was pregnant with t'challa's son at the
time of thanos's snap in the Battle of
wakanda and notice how here Nakia
catches herself she almost says t'challa
was also the father to her son but she
just says that he everything which he
was behind Nakia water just slowly
starts to flood into the street we don't
even notice it at first Okoye just
begins to say we are under attack but
then the water bombs explode throughout
the streets now Namor flooding wakanda
was a plot point in 2012 Avengers vs
X-Men comic storyline that's when the
Phoenix Force possessed its name or
infuses him to flood wakanda when the
nation Harbors Avengers Neymar and
t'challa have a bitter hatred for each
other ever since that in the comics
Okoye grabs a kid as the water gushes
and hands them off Ayo and the other
door milage save some rescue workers who
get enchanted by the teleconneal siren
songs shuri and Anika pilot an aircraft
to save a trolley we actually saw one of
these on the streets in the 2018 film
it's just pretty satisfying to see all
levels of wakandans immediately spring
in to help each other no more joins
atuma and nomura on the shoreline and
imbaka jumps them from behind but breaks
his staff on his arm and the more
punches him right in the chest breaking
his chest armor Brian coogler said that
nomore is the strongest Thor and if he's
rounding up water is the strongest Hulk
I actually recently broke down the power
hierarchy in the MCU and since no more
is technically the Avatar of a God that
kind of checks out with the mcu's
internal Logic the more zigzags through
the air defenses he does his mid-air
turn with his foot passing the camera
showing his ankle Wings flapping over
time the more it flies up to the throne
room to face off with Ramona and Riri
inside he stabs his spear into the glass
and cracks it then throws water grenades
and floods the room Ramon is able to
save Riri but she drowns and sure he is
inconsolable so shuri has to go through
another Royal burial this time for her
mother now ironically by not burning her
funeral garments before she left them to
be used again just imagine how horrible
it is you just were closer to your
brother's funeral and before they even
have a chance to gather Dusty gotta put
them back on for your mother yet the
answer cherries woes is literally
tattooed on her hand the double helix
configuration with orbs her attempt at
the recipe for the heart-shaped herb and
now on the same wrist is the final
ingredient she needs nemour's mother's
bracelet that is made from that plant
meanwhile Val confronts her ex-husband
Ross on his contact with wakanda
Anderson Cooper cameos again but this
time the new sticker reads Ritson signed
trade pact with new Asgard to create
something but this isn't not to the new
U.S president ritzen who's gonna be
played by Dermot Mulroney in secret
Invasion so again we're getting us into
the political hierarchy U.S president
secretary of state Toby Ziegler and CIA
director Val it's still crazy to write
my head around that also this is a
reminder that like wakanda the colony of
new Asgard led by King Valkyrie is in
the MCU its own nation state with
international relations across the world
stage now Ross reminds us that the
wakandans could be using their vibranium
against the United States and ask Vala
she's ever thought what the US would be
doing if we were the only country in the
world to add vibranium and Val's
response is interesting she says oh I
actually dream about that I miss a
little hint that one of Val's objectives
is to amass all the vibranium and
weaponry under government control or at
least under her control and maybe the
mission she's going to deploy the
Thunderbolts on is an invasion of or a
heist from wakanda or since Bucky's lead
in that team may be a collaboration with
the dorm Elijah to steal back vibranium
from some other third party who steals
it like the real intelligencia so the
Golden City evacuates to the Jabari
Outpost sharian reread deduce that
nemour absorbs oxygen through his skin
and thus will be weakened by dehydration
gets to work on new Iron Art armor made
from vibranium she hammers out a piece
in the shape of a heart Sharia gives
akoye her completed Midnight Angel suit
in the comics the midnight angels are a
naked group of former Jor molache sure
he is able to synthesize the
heart-shaped herb DNA from the bracelet
and when it prints it successfully glows
so shuri sips the liquid and falls into
the ancestral plane as Nakia nokoye pray
for her now structurally this mirrors
the leap of faith at the end of Act 2 in
the 2018 film when the women resurrected
t'challa to restore wakanda's protector
shuri immediately finds herself in an
ancestral plane mirror of the real world
underwater in the flooded throne room in
the exact same spot where her mother
Ramona's life left her body just like
how when killmonger went to the
ancestral plane he visited the exact
spot of his parents tragic death Cherie
swims up to the surface and she's again
wearing her White Funeral garments but
as she Rises out of the water her
clothes are dry a really cool effect
that makes me wonder if Leticia writing
Ryan coogler might have shot this in
Reverse but here in the throne room we
see there is someone sitting on the
throne behind her suddenly we all feel a
mix of dread because none of us want to
see a cji recreation of Chad with
Bozeman it can't be him it can't be so
instead the ghost who greets us is
killmonger Michael B Jordan making a
surprise Cameo which comes as both the
relief but also an intriguing Haunting
of its own the scene that follows is my
favorite scene in the film cutting deep
to the core conflict of this film while
also re-contextualizing everything we
saw in the 2018 film remember the
ancestral plane is not an objective
afterlife it's really a personalized
Vision where the visitor is able to
confront their ancestors there's some
Cosmic forces at play that decide who
you actually need to talk to one could
say this is a request coming from one's
own soul but for t'challa it was to rage
against his father for killing and jobu
and abandoning jaka for killmonger it
was his chance to revisit the Oakland
apartment where his father died but who
does Sherry see she sees her cousin
killmonger who taunts her saying you
chose me and he challenges her for not
even believing the ancestral plane was
real but just took the herb for the same
reason he did to avenge Fallen ancestors
now remember as much as this is
killmonger talking to her we could
totally look at this as shuri having a
conversation with herself and all the
second guessing she's been doing about
killmonger over the past several years
so why did Cherie seek hillmonger she
already chose him earlier in the film
when she said at that Riverside campfire
that she wanted to burn the world down
that was killmonger's goal and notice
how in this scene the throne room
ignites the same way killmonger set the
heart-shaped herb garden Ablaze and left
Sherry with that medical crisis here
killmonger defends himself he says I had
the courage to do what was necessary to
change wakanda how many people like your
scientists to wakanda protect before I
took the throne cowards those are the
Panthers who came before me and before
t'challa sure he tells killmonger that
he was coward for taking a last Urban
burning the rest out of fear of being
replaced that he left wakanda with no
protector and that's a challenge
Ramona's blood is on his hands the
killmonger responds don't you dare take
that away from your mother she
sacrificed her life to protect a girl
from The Lost tribe your father he was a
hypocrite he would have killed that girl
[ __ ] he killed his own brother t'challa
he was too Noble he led a man who killed
your father live and here you stand are
you gonna be Noble like your brother or
take care of business like me killmonger
calls Riri a member of the Lost tribe
which is how he saw himself and all
other black people outside of wakanda
the lives that he fought for killmonger
also invokes Zemo killed tachaka and
t'challa for gave Zemo at the end of
Civil War I like to think that Zemo at
this moment stiffened in his cell on the
Wrath feeling to shiver down his spine
but then just resume dancing it's so so
interesting to see killmonger eternally
sitting on the throne now again shuri
has subconsciously summoned him here but
this visual presents a hypothetical that
killmonger could be in a kind of Hell of
his own making where he's sitting on the
throne that he always wanted but ruling
over a vacant dead kingdom while all
other Panther ancestors joined together
into communion as Panthers in a tree
killmonger tragically will always be
part of a lost track of one this scene
ends before shuri can even answer
killmonger's question framing it as a
haunting nightmare that she's still
trying to figure out for the rest of the
film she's afraid to tell others who she
saw in that Vision out of shame because
killmonger was a symptom of her own
moral illness that this physician still
needs to heal but sure he still has
super strength and she suits up in a new
suit she places her helmet beside the
helmet of her brother the helmet that
she carried in the opening funeral
scenes now she has a helmet of her own
and sure he joins everyone else at the
Jabari Outpost fully suited up
interesting how she joins by descending
from above the way nemour set his throne
shuri does not rise up she drops down
she's still being driven by the
misguided Vengeance that guides him more
and guided killmonger when she lands I
like how the impact spreads via purple
kinetic energy as her suit absorbs the
shock of it her helmet has a DOT pattern
that matches the war paint that she's
worn from past battles also on her
gauntlets or open Panther moths sure he
leads wakandas out to the ocean and
lures the teleconneal into battle she
chants Evon Bay that was t'challa's war
cry from the Battle of Condon Infinity
War since the Moore's punch broke his
old chest plate mbaku suits up with new
armor burying the face of Hanuman that's
the ape deity of the Jabari worship the
telekinil attacked for the backs of blue
whales and orcas their Shields I'm
pretty sure the shells of sea turtles
awesome the more it breaks the pulsy
device the wakandans use to try to
subdue them actually Jessica Clemens
interviewed Alex lubinali and Mabel
Cadena asking about their underwater
work for this film and Alex confirmed
that Mabel holds the record she's
six minutes you can hold your breath
underwater six minutes and a half you're
a fish ReRe joins a fight and her Mark
two armor it's got an inner heads up
display of her head and darkness
surrounded by glowing indicators much
like Iron Man's heads-up display one of
her controls reads max power I like
actually also installed some foot
thrusters similar to Tony's Mark 50
armor in Infinity War Riri shoots it
into more from behind but he's able to
dodge the blast without looking crazy
good reflexes they're able to snare no
more on the Royal Talent fighter sure he
uses hand mounted Sonic cannons to repel
the telekineal like the ones that's used
on killmonger in the 2018 film she claws
down the side of the boat kicking one
telekineal throwing another Barrel
rolling and then sliding down since both
her claws and the whole of this voter
made a vibranium they released blue
Sparks from the friction and from here
she leaps into the Royal Talon fighter
where she tries to fly no more to a
nearby desert to finish him off but
before they get there he's able to use
his spear to stab through the fighter
and wreck the engine causing it to crash
leading to this brutal Showdown the
claws come out jury and the more Slug It
Out She Dodges this hook and goes low
slice slicing off some of his ankle
Wings he impales her on his Spear and
since it's pure vibranium it goes
through her suit's vibranium weave it
seems like it's all over as her life
Fades she's transported back to the
ancestral plane the burning Throne Room
briefly her greatest fear that being
consumed with killmonger's ventral rage
has led her to death but instead she now
rejects that path she claws off the
spear she pulls herself off a bit
somehow leaving no blood on the shaft of
that spear okay and leaps over no more
and lands before him and she uses the
exploding jet engine to blast no more
presumably most effective just by drying
him out even further and as she holds
the blade to his throat both Fighters
are close to death and they sink in this
fascinating interlocking visions of
their ancestors for sure the conflicts
of the past rewind we see the flooding
in the battles before reversing
symbolizing her wounds beginning to heal
both the physical wounds in her suit and
her psychological illness her mind is
retracing its steps back to the mutually
peaceful kingdoms of wakanda and talukan
and finally shuri sees the ancestor she
wanted to see in the ancestral plane a
vision of her mother Ramona who says
show him who you are and sure he tells
them more to yield so that Their
Kingdoms can protect each other no more
looks at Butchery and what does he see
he sees the vision of his mother
reaching down to him on the sacred
ground these two have found the wisdom
of their ancestors a closing Montage of
shuri replanting the heart-shaped herb
garden in t'challa's grave site she
greets Riri in the lab and makes her
return the suit but leaves her with the
car of her father that akoye wrecked on
the bridge earlier not having this super
vibranium suit's probably a good idea
because this way where he was going to
be set up to build a new DIY armor set
in Iron Heart on Disney Plus in 2023 we
return to Warrior balls but instead of
shuri coming out of the royal Talon
fighter it's mbaku he says the Black
Panther sure he sends her regards but
Baku wishes to challenge for the throne
this sets up mbaku to be the new ruler
of wakanda while shuri continues to be
black panther at least an intermediary
one we catch it back with namora nomura
in his Peyton cave seems as though
things are still a bit unresolved and we
realize no more has been painting all
this time a depiction of himself and a
panther locked in battle Okoye rescues
Ross from captivity making him a
fugitive from the American government
and leaving Okoye in her Midnight Angel
suit finally with some headgear that
she's comfortable in the final scene
brings shuri to a beach in Haiti where
she finally allows herself to burn her
funeral garments she closed her eyes and
meditates and she flashes back to the
images of t'challa from the 2018 film
when he walked down the hallway to her
lab and gave his sister their handshake
when she placed his necklace suit on him
after he resurrected the first time he
walked into the throne room as king as
she finally breathes to let go of her
brother she and we are lulled by
Rihanna's lift me up the lyrics of which
become shuri's prayer to her brother
Lift Me Up Hold Me Down hold me close
safe and sound now burning in a hopeless
dream Echoes the fire of the despair
that she felt in her nightmare with
killmonger in the second verse that part
becomes drowning in an Endless Sea a
contrast to Fire and Water there but
both represent killmonger and no more
dragging shuri down into violence which
is why the chorus comes back to the
prayer of lift me up and in the
post-credits scene her prayers are
answered Nakia introduces Sherry to her
nephew to Saint Sherry says the name to
Saint carries a history referring to to
Saint the Overture sorry if I
mispronounced that my French sucks but
this guy was awesome called the black
Napoleon the father of Haiti who in 1791
led a successful slave revolt against
the French and one Haitian Independence
I think what I love most about this line
is that it signals sure he has through
her wakanda Outreach centers that she
built with t'challa has begun to learn
more black history from outside wakanda
and has begun to reconnect with that
lost tribe that killmonger fought for I
mean I don't know I'm sure he's pretty
smart maybe she already knew this stuff
but it did seem like in the 2018 film
all she really seemed to know about the
outside world was like Disneyland and
Back to the Future too Saint reveals
that his real name is t'challa son of
King t'challa he would be no more than
six or seven years old so we would need
a bit of a time job before we see any
real superhero action for this kid even
if he were to join a group like the
Young Avengers but a new t'challa lives
he has his whole life ahead of him and
he knows where he comes from and who his
baba was the Black Panther is not a
burden story must carry alone anymore
her brother is gone but wakanda is
forever now definitely go watch Jessica
Clement's thoughtful review of wakanda
forever that's on the channel along with
mt's insightful breakdown the
post-credits scene I truly appreciate
you all giving me this opportunity to
break down this powerful film to bring
my nerdy analysis to this artistic
achievement of Ryan coogler and his
whole team as Marvel phase four comes to
a close as we look ahead to phase five
stay tuned for some big announcements
about some new projects where you will
be able to see me dive even deeper into
the details you missed from the films
you love there's some big things ahead
for new rock stars in 2023 I can't wait
to share them with you follow me on Tick
Tock Instagram and Twitter at eavos
follow new rockstars subscribe to new
rockstars for more analysis of
everything you love thanks for watching
bye
[Music]